oh my god the restaurant killed it
I contacted the hotel and told them I
want the most romantic table in this
resort and my hope is that for a rose
and I to grow closer together and just
relax and just kind of be with each
other I just want to take this in right
now just be with you I didn't even tell
you how beautiful you look tonight
thank you you'll be beauti I'll be the
Beast
[Laughter]
it will have a look because he banding
it to each other I want a part of my
life so I wish that he proposed to me
this night so what do you think you're
happy yes of course
well I'm happy too so the main reason
why I wanted to come here with you
was for us to really understand our
feelings what you want I want someone
that loves me that won't ever leave me
that respects me do you want that with
me
No
I mean I think so but I'm I'm not 100%
sure
I love rose but there's one thing that's
holding me back and that is whether or
not Rose was involved with her sister
asking me for money why I'm not going
under this person because I can I
explain after dinner can we eat first
and I'll explain oh thank you I want you
to tell me now
explain me
[Music]